[Music]
I can sense a rumbling the seismic
graphs are showing the same readings as
they did before December last year this
means the second trailer is coming out
sooner than we
think yo what's up guys so we know that
Godzilla K the new Empire is going to be
out in less than 2 months time preone to
the 29th of March from the 12th of April
that's old news the new news will be the
second trailer that will be out either
this Sunday or early Monday coinciding
with the ground Hawk day and a Super
Bowl so here in this video we will
discuss 10 things we can expect to see
in the upcoming trailer for the movie so
let's get to it so in the first trailer
they began with saying how we humans
believe that life could only exist in
the surface of the planet now in the
second one they most probably will
expand on that and reveal most shots of
the hollow Earth along with statements
about the Titans and life inside the
enigmatic Subterranean world as well as
reveal a bit more on the ancient human
civilization that still thrives there
they did show us Hollow Earth people in
the first trailer and bits and pieces of
Gia as well as the other characters
meeting them similar to how the
characters of 2017 Skull Island made
contact with the ews but don't expect
too much about it it'll just be glimpses
and short scenes as this is just a
trailer the second thing that would
definitely be shown is how the world has
slowly become accustomed to Godzilla and
its rule over the planet something that
the whole premise behind in 2014 king of
the monsters and GVK movies was really
about they would replay the same
Godzilla in the Coliseum scene but add
more insight to the fact that the Big G
is here to stay don't expect to see the
Iraq net Titan in Rome though that'll be
too much of a reveal so okay another one
Titan shimu has to be finally seen by
hook or by crook the toys the toy cover
images the leaks the clothing designs
all point to his existence in the movie
The Jig Is up the whole world probably
knows about him or her keeping shimo in
the dark for the second trailer would
just antagonized fans of the
monsterverse like you and I who know
more than the Layman on the streets also
adding a short clip of shimu in the
trailer with just juice everything up
and raise the hype for the movie as to
how the scene BS out it's up to you to
make a guess but I'm thinking that he
will appear in the Giza Hol Earth tunnel
in Egypt emerging right after the Kong
in that same
place okay so scar King is the real bad
guy of the movie the director himself
stated that and he also said that he is
too big for either Kong or Godzilla to
deal with alone so what does that mean
what does he mean by too big this might
either be too big in terms of size or
too big in terms of the level of threat
and power he possesses so in the first
trailer and the first teaser of last
year we only saw scaring as either a
silhouette or as in closeup shots what
would definitely be badass is to show
the full body of the enemy Titan and
from that we might assertain his true
size and
design of course expect to see more
shots of Godzilla in his evolved form
and yeah he was seen in full in the
first trailer and I'm betting they would
only reveal slightly long sequences of
the earlier shots and from that we would
be lucky to have a more detailed look at
his new evolved form and yeah we have
seen Godzilla and Kong together running
side by side in the hollow Earth we can
expect to see them face to face though
in this new trailer something that might
tease a fight again between these two
talents or maybe just them making a
truce keeping us guessing while at the
same time hyping us up all right so they
would repeat the ending of the Chinese
trailer here in the second one as well
the part where Kong will get the Beast
glove a mechanical contraption that
would help The Big Ape in his fight
against the colossal threats later in
the movie to add to this they would also
have a long sequence of the part where
Co emerges from beneath the Giza
Pyramids in Egypt with the glove on by
that time he and the gadget would be
hand in hand so to say so expect more
shots of our new Godzilla in his evolved
form and also moreal scenes of Kong with
the Beast glove the Titan
Gauntlet of course the new Empire is
said to be an end of thee World scenario
type of movie a Titan Apocalypse movie
that will Eclipse king of the monsters
in scale of Destruction and also it'll
be a WrestleMania of the Titans as in
GVK combining both aspects of the
earlier movies so expect to see mass
chaos and destruction to befall the
human world so as to create a sense of
panic and also creating a sense of the
scale of the Calamity to be Unleashed
blast explosions Atomic breaths
everything that is shining and
gratifying to
see okay so maybe it's just me but maybe
they might add a short sequence about
the ancient Titan war that has been
teased since the end credits of the
first ever Movie 2014 not 1954 of course
we saw the afterm of it in the throne
room of the Kongs in GVK as well as in
the art book The novelization of GVK and
the many Comics but there hasn't been a
statement about it in the movies this is
a bit farfetched to see in a trailer or
to get even a statement of it in a
trailer but it'll definitely be
something that will pop up in the
movie legendary has revealed some behind
the- scene images of the Monarch
operatives in the hollow Earth this
would mean that Monarch has been quite
busy there and aside from the Titan
reveals and scenes of Destruction it'll
be quite good to see something of The
Human Side you know showcasing the human
characters in more detail maybe the
monar Bas their activity G the other
characters in The Hollow Earth as well
as more intense on liners of the main
cast members that's may be definitely a
given maybe lessen up on the lame jokes
like you know my lame jokes you know the
lame jokes like oh is that a mini Kong
but this is given these human scenes
will definitely be added in in the
second
trailer and lastly in the first trailer
we saw awesome Titans we've never seen
before like the W dogs the hollow Earth
Kongs suko and the scar King you know
the new entries for this movie but get
ready for more new Titan teasers sadly
definitely not a mo reveal but maybe a
titanis duck return a fan favorite of
the show and probably his interaction
with suko the mini Kong now those are
the 10 things we expect to see in the
second trailer of gxk the new Empire and
with that we come to the end of this
video like subscribe and we'll see you
in the next one take care
fam